die auftritte waren mehr als 4000
menschen auf sich warten
um den mangel an wohnraum zu stehen und
ihre unerwartet die hälfte heißt im
französischen original den kram passt
also das prophezeien wo wir doch schon
benannt ist was das extrem etf haben sie
denn quadratmeter noch dabei oder chef
[Musik]
das großer teil was wir uns in paris
wohnungsnot zu gemeine große kältewelle
und so geschichte regierung und er die
komödie ausdrücklich nicht erwähnt
welche politische farbe 4 angehört ein
sehr praktisches experimente sprung zur
em quartier ungen das ist eben der
gegenstand mit der komödie in deren
mittelpunkt eine familie name ist die
größte die eben vater mutter und eine
schlecht gelaunte tochter redest du
nicht
der film handelt wie die meisten
komödien von den menschlichen schwächen
und macht sicher weil er ihnen den will
ich mal fragen luft über darf nicht den
menschen miteinander umgehen
aber im kern ist dann doch ein völlig
grafisches die praktische tipps wie man
auch sehr gut auch auf die aktuellen
politischen und sozialen verhältnisse in
europa um regal
[Musik]
für eine wirklich große komödie ist der
film vermutlich ein bisschen zu harmlos
und zusagen von gesamtanlage aber ich
glaube aufgrund beispiel die politische
gemengelage der gegenwart apportieren
wir ihm auch mit dem klischee vom
liefern wir mit dem mit der atmosphäre
in das französische groß oder mittels
bürgertums spielen hätte eine ganze
menge von serien vertreten und auch
unterhaltsamen auftakt ein wunderbares
arbeitsform hinzu so dass ich sagen
würde der film auf jeden fall
empfehlenswert ist vieles daran gibt
durch eine misslungene verhalten
verlaufen für wissenschaft bilden wird
[Musik]